hey guys what's up we have been working
on something interesting and it is
mechanical in nature we know that they
are quite a few size comparison videos
about robots but our list will beat them
all with the 20 biggest movie robots in
this list we include famous ones like
the Irish ayan Mechagodzilla and all but
we decided to put in just 2 or 3 entries
from Yeager's of the Pacific Rim and
from the Transformers as they would no
doubt Lee flood the entire rankings so
before you continue please subscribe and
hit that notification bell so here are
20 biggest robots and mecca's from
movies number 20 edy 209 the enforcement
droid series 209 or edy 209 were a fully
automated series of peacekeeping
machines created by Omni consumer
products in the movie Robocop the units
were programmed for urban pacification
but OCP also negotiated contracts with
the military for use in war when Robocop
attempted to arrest dick Jones he
deployed 80209 and a bastard Robocop
with its cannons then smacked him across
the room 80209 then attempted to shoot
Robocop in his visor but Robocop forced
its blasting left arm into his right
destroying it this robot is 11 feet tall
or 3.3 5 meters
number 19 God God is a fictional
humanoid robot that appears first in the
1951 20th Century Fox American science
fiction film The Day the Earth Stood
Still and later in his 2008 remake its
depiction varies between film
adaptations the nature of gods was
almost completely altered in the 2008
remake God's name was given by the
United States military and scientists as
G ort which stands for genetically
organized robotic technology in this
movie adaptation although there were no
exact specification we can make out that
he was around 45 to 50 feet tall or
around 14 to 15 meters number 18 the are
enjoins the Iranian is a large 50 foot
tall metal man of alien origin and the
deuteragonist of the film adapted from
the original novel by Ted here
the Ironman while capable of incredible
destructive powers and equipped with
highly advanced and destructive weaponry
the air engine would not ever want to
harm anyone or any living thing when he
first came to earth the air engine had a
bump on his head and I was holding back
info from it suits defense systems the
air engine would only allow his suit to
activate its defense weapons in
self-defense
number 17 the harvester the harvester is
a large bipedal nonhumanoid
hunter-killer unit produced by Skynet
sometime before 2016 seen in Terminator
Salvation this giant robot is 18 metres
or 60 feet tall and his primary function
is to capture humans for the machines to
do lab testing on stem cells when a
harvester has captured any human test
subject it calls a transport which
arrives and lands somewhere near the
harvester located on the back left of
the harvester is a large scale
electrically-charged plasma cannon which
obliterates its targets upon contact
number 16 mechanical mechanical is a
remote control robot
double of King Kong introduced in a 1966
animated television series the King Kong
show and featured again in a 1967 film
King Kong escapes the robot was created
by dr. who who tried to replicate the
giant ape King Kong mechanical was 20
meters or 65 feet tall and weighed
fifteen thousand metric tons mechanical
is the creation of the villainous Doctor
Who as mad scientist bent on world
domination and a sworn enemy of King
Kong mechanic Kong's name comes from the
word mechanical and calm part of the
King Kong's name number 15 the Omni
droid
he only droids are a secondary
antagonist of the Incredibles they are a
series of superhero killing battle
robots created by the supervillain
syndrome as a part of Operation Chronos
the Amun droids are programmed with an
artificial intelligence that allows them
to learn as it fights his opponents and
to solve any problem they encounter the
pinnacle of the Amun droid series the
Omni droid version 10 was designed by
syndrome for the final stage of
operation Chronos it is the largest at
70 feet tall or 21.5 meters and it is
the smallest and
this version of the ama droids number 14
Megazord
in the 2017 Power Rangers movie the
Zords are alien battle vehicles that
have taken the form of the most powerful
beasts on the world neil anonym in this
case the Cenozoic era earth the Megazord
which is 282 feet tall or 25 metres is
the combination of the five battled
Zords t-rex pterodactyl Mastodon
Triceratops and Sabretooth the Megazord
has jet thrusters on its feet
retractable wings that can transform
into twin power swords twin cannons on
its left wrist and a blade that can
extend on its right wrist number 13 the
Dinobots the Janna was a group of
Autobot transformers who appears and
transformers the age of extinction they
were rescued and freed from lockdown
ship and immediately their leader
Grimlock challenged Optimus Prime to a
fight and when Prime one he agreed to
fight alongside the are BOTS against the
Decepticons in Hong Kong there is strife
sloth scorn and Grimlock and out of them
the biggest is gone and eighty seven
feet tall or twenty six point five
meters tall
followed by Grimlock and 84 feet tall or
twenty five point six meters tall and
the other two at seventy and fifty seven
feet tall
number twelve Mechagodzilla this version
of the metal kaiju is from ready player
one
Mechagodzilla also referred as Kiryu is
a mecha vehicle option for players in
the Oasis the vehicles based on a kg of
the same name from Godzilla film
franchise the villain Nolan Sorrento
Paris this mech during the Battle of
Castle in Iraq in the final scenes of
the movie it is one of the largest mechs
available in the game
standing at 30 metres or 98 feet tall
Mechagodzilla is near indestructible and
has a powerful atomic breath attack but
is happened by its slow speed and
maneuverability number 11
Devastator seen in Transformers Revenge
of the Fallen the Devastator is an
immensely powerful warrior and in a
sense the combination of the construct
cons into a mush being is impressive
whether he is formed from six to nine
constructicon devastator is a giant
among Giants he is so huge in fact that
his body simply cannot support itself
when carrying his weight a bright
forcing him to lumber on all fours
devastated is named after Cybertron so
on
Sanibel and terrifyingly destructive
Devastator wins in the revenge of the
Fallen he stated to be a hard and 8 feet
tall or 33 metres nam attend tripods in
the most recent film adaptation of War
of the Worlds tripods were featured as a
squid jellyfish-like design for this
design it has two windshields that are
on both sides of the dome like head a
dozen or more tentacles that can be
retracted these war machines are
evidently taller than any other
adaptation at a hundred fifty feet tall
to be exact
bigger than a 1953 designs of the war
machine in this adaptation the tripods
have been waiting beneath the ground for
countless years to be activated by the
returning aliens number 9 Jet Jaguar Jet
Jaguar is a heroic mecha created by Toho
that first appeared in a 1973 Godzilla
film Godzilla vs. Megalon jet Jagger was
the result of a contest Toho had in the
mid to late 1972 for fast to come out
with new heroes for them to use Jet
Jaguar was a human-sized robot created
by invent seguro de Buci for unknown
reasons having been stolen by the
underground nation of sea topia a Jag
was mission was to guide mega Long's to
Tokyo so the insect kaiju could destroy
it could grow to a maximum of a hundred
and sixty-four feet tall
of 50 meters number 8 Chronos way back
in time during the time of Elvis a movie
came out and it was praised for its
unique storytelling
so Kronos is a 1957 independently made
american black-and-white science-fiction
film from regal films in the movie the
robot Kronos is an energy accumulator
sent by an alien race that has exhausted
its own natural resource they have sent
their giant war machine to drain all of
the Earth's available power and then
return to their dying world Kronos
science wasn't given but our estimates
put it at somewhere between 200 and 200
feet tall
number seven Dallas Dallas was an
enormous Bronx giant armed with a salt
who protected Europe from pirates and
thieves in jason and the argonauts
although he was 70 metres tall in the
film jason and the argonauts dallas was
8 feet tall in the actual mythology
dallas became the first major obstacle
in Jason's journey after landing on
Crete or the Isle of bronze
Jason ordered his men to take only food
and water and not to disturb the
treasures of the island this course tell
us to think the Argonauts were pirates
for he defended the treasure number 6
[ __ ] danger and [ __ ] Avenger these
entries are from the Pacific Rim
universe and we decided to Club them
together as they are almost identical
another reason as to why this entry and
the next from the Pacific Rim is going
to be a group of robots is that there
are too many of them anyway [ __ ] danger
appears in the first Pacific Rim film
and as a gigantic robot maker that is
piloted by to humans mentally linked to
each other it's size is 260 feet tall or
79 meters and its successor [ __ ]
Avenger is a more advanced version and
appears in the Pacific Rim uprising and
this one is 268 feet tall or 81 meters
number 5 Cherno alpha channel alpha is a
mark 1 Russian Jaeger piloted by
husband-and-wife duo Sasha and Alexis
kaidanovsky channel alpha was the last
of the mark 1 Jaeger series and the
oldest Jaeger still active in combat
before its destruction in 2025 this
title appears in the first Pacific Rim
film and is to Iran 80 feet tall or
eighty five point three meters just a
side note
there are numerous Yeager's that are
made and still exist in the franchise
and most of them are between the sizes
of gypsy and Cherno alpha and to include
them all would only become the biggest
Jaeger video number 4 mo Gera PO Gera is
un built mecha created by Toho that
first appeared in a 1994 Godzilla film
Godzilla vs. space Godzilla
mogera was a unique case into Skyzoo
library as it did not have any actual
rows but it did however have sounds for
its engines and beam attacks
it was constructed from the leftover
pieces of Mechagodzilla
in another attempt to kill Godzilla it
could split into two different vehicles
the land Nogueira and a star Falcon
mogera has expensive arsenal of weapons
essentially making it a mobile weapons
platform number three Mechagodzilla
Mechagodzilla is a mecha that first
appeared in the 1974 Godzilla film
Godzilla vs. Mechagodzilla to date there
have been four distinct incarnations of
mecha godzilla featuring in the Godzilla
franchise the first was introduced in
1974 and Godzilla vs. Mechagodzilla the
second and the hasty series in a
nineteen entry film Godzilla vs.
Mechagodzilla - the third also known as
Kiryu first appeared in the film
Godzilla against Mechagodzilla in the
2002 the four incarnation of mecha
godzilla made a brief appearance in the
plan of the monsters their sizes are
Showa 50 meters hey Aaron 20 meters
millennium and 60 minutes and Ray were
at 50 meters respectively number 2
driller the largest subterranean
life-form native to Cybertron gorillas
are not to be taken lightly in almost
multi-tentacled beasts capable of
borrowing through the ground or through
buildings with ease they are capable of
great destruction and garnish on any
scale naturally all these qualities have
endeared them to shockwave who keeps one
as a pet and personal transport
according to the special effects team
the driller is the length of three
football fields
that would make it roughly 1,000 80 feet
long or 330 meters long it was seen in
transformers the dark of the Moon and a
number one spot goes to Mata Nui the
Mata Nui was a great spirit created by
the great beings to explore and observe
the galaxy for time he was condemned to
an eternal slumber with many Toa going
on journeys to revive him upon mata
newest death after the Toa Mari failed
to save the universe
Maduro sacrificed himself dying so that
Mata Nui could live again with Mata Nui
alive once more Tahu and his allies
journeyed to Karda Nui to awaken the
Great Spirit
Mata Nui was set to tower above the
clouds so he could have easily been over
2 kilometers tall he was seen in the
movie Bionicle to the legends of metru
nui and with this we come to the end of
the list and we hope you liked it so do
give a thumbs up and share it with a few
of your friend nerds anyway it has been
a blah
so see you guys next time